[Música]
aqui estamos como é bom conversar quem
não aprende uma boa conversa está
falando de boas conversas não estou
falando de monólogos e é sobre isso que
eu vim falar quanto maior a interação
maior será a aprendizagem não dá uma
olhada nessa típica sala de aula mas é
uma típica infelizmente muito atual sala
de aula nem todo mundo né brasil
conseguiu ainda a rebentar as paredes
o que nós vemos uma sala como essa ajuda
interagir promove a interação gente vai
precisar de vocês eu tô falando de
interação
então eu quero compartilhar com vocês
uma pesquisa sobre a taxa de
aprendizagem de molhada o que salta aos
olhos que chama atenção é isso
quando os nossos meninos e meninas
discutem grupo aprendem fazem coisas ou
ensino uns aos outros
muda tudo tudo melhora
é tudo isso que a gente está vendo
destas 11 da manhã ou não e se nós
sabemos disso
a pergunta pra todos nós exatamente essa
enquanto que essas estratégias ocupam as
nossas rotinas fazem parte das nossas
escolas e das nossas salas de aula não
como eventos mas como política nessas
muitas andanças que fazemos o instituto
sidarta
a buscar respostas às muitas
inquietações que nós temos
encontramos a professora leite ou luta
da universidade tempo
a right to fez uma pesquisa muito focada
nessas discussões e diz que trabalhar em
grupo é uma ferramenta poderosa para
trabalhar a integração e fazer com que a
aprendizagem seja muito mais
significativa mas quando a gente pensa
em trabalhar em grupo que memória vem
pra gente é quem não lembra do papel
massuh quem não lembra daquele amigo que
tinha a letra bonita e que tinha que
passar cada todo o trabalho a limpo o
amigo que tinha a letra artísticas sabia
desenhar a responsável por fazer a capa
e o mais descolado
era o que apresentava a professora
sempre começa a organizar o grupo
vamos gente vamos lá grupo que começa a
dar um exemplo dessa sensação de frio na
barriga já começa a montar as panelinhas
olhares aponta chama 1 mas sempre fica
alguém pé
alguém que não foi escolhido como fica
para essas pessoas que sabem que naquela
situação de julgamento dizem escuta não
tem lugar pra mim talvez não me vejo um
potente para poder fazer parte disso
e aí vem a professora de novo tentando
encaixar se tiver uma situação de
habilidade
olha ali tem três entrar lá o cara já
mãe
nesse momento a gente pode estar criando
uma situação para o resto da vida a
gente pode está silenciando esse menino
pra sempre e é isso que a gente tem que
pensar então eu quero falar de um outro
dado de silêncio
vocês sabiam que professores e me incluo
fala em média 50 minutos durante uma
situação de aula e que um aluno além
média 5 entre situações autorizadas ou
não e ainda bem né
agora se o professor efetivamente quiser
se conectar com seu aluno
ele deveria usar até 5 slides ou falar
dez minutos vejam que nós que estamos
passando até dex são paulo me deram oito
minutos pra falar de uma educação para a
vida não foi isso brasil ea gente como o
que vai dar
gente eu poder de síntese é uma escolha
e vejam bem nós temos um estádio lotado
então funciona
vamos aprender nós que estamos na escola
precisamos olhar pra isso eu quero
mostrar e contar pra vocês que quando a
gente pensa numa situação de interação
três palavras vem à minha mente e são
essas que eu procuro fazer tudo que eu
faço em educação usa nossas palavras
como norteadores da minha vida
é preciso coragem é preciso ousadia e
precisa empatia
nós precisamos fazer e te um desejo
genuíno de acolher o outro
nós precisamos propor atividades
intelectual mente mais desafiadoras pra
eles
precisamos acreditar que todos eles são
capazes de aprender
precisamos deixar com que eles conversem
com que eles argumentem com que eles
criem hipóteses e que cheguem e percebam
que não existe um único caminho a nossa
data quando nós vamos trabalhar em grupo
nós usamos algumas normas eu vou falar
de duas pra vocês
primeiro a gente diz o seguinte todos
têm o direito de perguntar e todos têm o
dever de responder não existe uma
pergunta ruim
nós temos que agradecer às perguntas
a escola é um lugar de indagação
a escola é um lugar de se viver a
pergunta e todos tem que acolher de uma
forma muito generosa esses
questionamentos ea outra questão é que
ninguém termina enquanto todos não
terminou
lembra do trabalho do márcio que vocês
riram quando era se escuta porque você
tá aí que está a fazer não já terminei a
minha parte não existe mais a sua parte
é tudo junto e misturado
todos têm que ser co-responsáveis pela
aprendizagem de do amigo do amigo ea
gente também vai trabalhar nesse aspecto
com a com outro professor
chega né nós ouvimos várias vezes várias
pessoas nesse mesmo tapete pedindo a
mesma coisa vamos deixar chega silenciar
nossas crianças de silenciar as nossas
classes de silenciar nossos professores
nós precisamos acreditar que todos são
capazes de aprender de formas diferentes
por que toda criança todo jovem é capaz
de aprender mas não necessariamente todo
adulto é capaz de ensinar e não tem
problema
aí eu pergunto que tipo de professor
nós escolhemos ser todos os dias quando
nós pisamos dentro das nossas salas de
aula que o professor
precisamos ser professores mais
ouvidores mais perguntadores do que
responder e dores
afinal quando a gente interage
aprendizagem é muito maior
eu sou professora por opção nunca foi
por falta dela
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]